is that the one that Top Gear always
calls about they really like just got
your turn and suddenly you're murdering
the entire city think that guy ran under
your tires
free shot everyone Holy Koran that thing
is finish that's lovely
[Music]
yeah the city that you're in right now
that's what I thought
well good you thought right my drills on
the Stars holy crap you didn't drive on
this I just did you saw me oh I thought
you're talking about a real-life Duncan
I've seen you're driving here I don't
know you this is Maggie no no no we'll
just don't die as much that's all I
gotta say tender look that's it from my
angle I don't know what it was just a
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
can I go
I think my car is very dead just look
here you're tired they bent the wrong
wing my humor is just too highbrow for
you to understand just beyond us
god that's turtle deal happen
Wow star I just hit my own car the
traffic mayor bottles a car hey hey
listen to me it's gonna talk you're
gonna get shot dude you do know you stay
there
how about you big [ __ ] whatever it's
all good get out I need this we're so
much more in stealth drop please do not
shoot me places to go and things to be I
don't know if this is gonna help you oh
is that another bus hmm you were a city
bus Hey - you go here sandy blowhole hey
friend Oh would you stop barn man we're
doing the wrong way and trapping the
slow bus all police just Rams you in the
rear end you're gonna die so hard if you
try and get out right now
not if you make a wall with your bus
that's a good idea thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
why are you looking at your crotch which
is a crotch blowing some things
something's going on
whoa you do that and let's get closer to
that you can't see I know I didn't say
she that said it's cheese you're uh
can't do that Oh we'll find out next
time one game rooms steam train I talked
to Barry in almost every video I do
Barry are you gonna sue us because if
you are that's okay that'd be very mean
of you shot the was that a punk the car
okay believe it that just landed in
front of you in the news parolees it's
not falling over get in this and it's
just gonna explode I'm also gonna get
into it very casually oh yes why are you
drunk
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
put on a helmet one hand aimed out with
the gun pointed your third hand inside
your pants is the Citroen Alabama
oh yeah I'm a good driver and we do like
the rules like no damage from that I
know cuz I'm wearing a helmet yeah
slow realization link both um sticks oh
you could have done that when you were
going faster I pray chase it down not
really do a highway robbery - I didn't
jump Alek you're right that's a great
idea
wait a minute yeah it's great take your
favorite color to jump into a minefield
oh go ahead you to use cheat codes I
actually played with Giulio he didn't
use a cheat code I might as well have
everyone out there like favorite
subscribe hey good work today oh you
can't do outside oh yeah do it it's on
purpose not allowing me to hit her yeah
all-star goddamn tringle do that guy
kick the door
yeah I wish that open when I did that up
now it opens yeah yeah it was a lock
before yeah you unlocked it with my
explosive kick exactly i explosive kick
area the explosive kicks from your loins
[ __ ] you fountain oh really fine fine
it's only fine okay some police I may
not seem like a lot now connects with
your face really really all right gonna
old lady that you're about to punch into
oblivion shot you're gonna need to pay
your medical bills punch those bullets
this is probably next she sounds old she
sounds old box ever do to you three
stars watchings dub i'm i have explosive
punch arena plunger yeah
I get it that was a pun and that was a
good one no one laughed not even in the
audience punch him in the face or be a
giant baby shut up shut up I'm gonna
hide in plain sight
[Music]
how are the car they're just shooting at
you alright now I blend in oh so now is
it no you skipped a turn oh he's gonna
totally murder these dudes yes about the
murder yeah look at him go let's watch
this cutscene of him man this is a
really poorly animated scene no yeah
yeah are you doing
this sweater vest dudes are tough Jesus
the old man that old Morgan Freeman
Morgan friggin he'll never sell the same
okay you want the super jump super jump
boom gravity I just told you you
activated it okay so you can't do it
when you're in a vehicle okay okay so
there's no traction on the moon wait no
no you invented this I wanna get a turn
[Music]
to the baby every it said jump and then
press circle to float after you jump I
[Laughter]
like the moon be rag doll Oh what do I
do
fly if you like trying to control it
Wow okay you're falling so freakin song
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I have creative control on the ankles
this would have gone so much better